[музика]
та ще поки загасив чорна клаву нейстат
і смаку за рядок врятував наш с і пародиста
[оплески]
почекати дає москалі корові базікати
люди з червоними смужками трипл ейч
документи
[музика]
мартинюк воюючи
трек
інакше постаралася а умільці про
викручені підлогу і рязаний і саша можна ось
троянда носиться голоду грудей це блювати щит
на бризковику не лякає [ __ ]
[музика]
гра не
захоплення просто я подав
mute і у вас обійняли і
породить мій підсумок
новачкам потяг до але не потрапляти на
ділянці футбольних
1-го будуть вони he
was with введення нот його піском і в
росії
[музика]
ariston свій паспорт я в завалі я в залі
громадян України
млинець
мартинюк
мартинюка а
три танки і я і
так порожнім шкіру мус або там далі пе-2
припиняй один танк лежить
слова поколінь України та
[оплески]
[музика]
навколо багаття сидять
охренеть
без метушні обертали gonna сирота хвала
україні та качки місії морозу російська
військовий корабель іди нахуй
ви
можете використовувати
[музика]
Ой ой
бляти своїм ходом
[музика]
добре слава україні
у цьому розібрали
добре
закон
[музика]
вона
[оплески]
самі.
[музика]